all the exercises that you've been
assigned so far have to do with areas
because that's and volumes as well
because that's kind of like the main
application of integration right so i
want to give you an example
of an area
when you have them with log functions
because of the work that we've just done
you now have two methods that you can
use to evaluate this okay
so for instance i'm drawing yourself up
a little sketch
of log x
and we'll do our we'll do a really
simple area
all right what's the intercept for
starters
one just one okay so let's do like i
said a nice simple area let's go up to
e so if that's two then two point seven
something like that
okay now this is log x by the way why
did i choose
e why is it actually going to give us
something simple
because it's just one as well uh okay so
when i'm when i'm
evaluating the integral or whatever it
is the e and the log x they're going to
mix together and it's going to be super
simple for us okay stuff is going to
cancel out we'll have nice numbers
okay i suppose i could have had like a
squared or e cubed
all of those will give us nice values
for the y-axis as you'll see in a second
okay so if i want to work out this area
okay i've got two alternatives i can use
this fancy thing that i've just created
okay
so a very common thing might be okay
here's your question
you know this is question 14 or
something like that
here's part a differentiate that part b
will be
hence write a statement for the integral
of this and then part c would be
okay give me an area okay and as you
guys know i hope
when you've got a part abc type question
right if they all say
show this show that hence
even if you can't show these things if
they are written down in the exam and
you're like i tried it and it just broke
down okay
but there's two marks over here and i
know how to use this stuff to get there
you can just assume it you start at part
c have nothing written for a
b and say blah blah is true from part a
and then you just start working okay so
even if you can't prove it you can still
use it
we already have proven it so how would
we use it here okay
well you just form the intervals nice
and easy what are the upper and lower
bounds
one to e get in the habit of saying the
lower one first because it's
in direction of an integral a definite
integral actually does matter yeah
this is the function we're integrating
with respect to x
okay now we know what the primitive is
because we just worked it out
because it's definite we don't need to
worry about
the constant okay so let's just go ahead
and evaluate
you do the upper bound first so i'm
going to get e times
log e you see what i mean okay minus e
then you subtract the amount so what are
we going to get
1 times log 1 minus
1. okay what's log eight
it's one so this is actually e minus b
minus what's log one zero at zero so
this is zero minus one
so this disappears that doesn't matter
double negative you get one you're like
what
will that work just for one so
there's your um there's your actual
sorry singular there's your area okay